seeit has invited automotive journalists
to a driving safety training session in
Innsbruck to test the limits of both Car
and Driver in winter conditions
Sebastian Stott explains what drivers
have to watch out for he points out that
the first thing we need in snow is good
winter tires obviously there's no tires
on this station wagon are optimal if
they're new the tread is deep and the
traction good also important are the
wiper blades drivers should always check
the wiper blades because the streaks bad
ones leave on the windshield are not
only annoying they can seriously
impaired visibility and he simulates a
situation where the headlights are
covered with snow they have to be
cleaned up
not only so you can see the road and a
heavy nighttime snowfall but so other
drivers can see you and if the hood is
carrying a heavy load of snow it's a
good idea to clear that off as well so
it doesn't blow up onto the windshield
and hamper visibility the snow should
also be scraped off the roof so it won't
blow onto the cars following along
behind and obscure their vision let's
fill fires on position on forecast
anybody entire pan is fine
also very important is the proper seat
position so the driver feels safe
Sebastien conducts what he calls a risk
test he lays his wrist on top of the
steering wheel palms down and has to
make sure his shoulders don't pull away
from the back seat if they do he knows
he has to push the seat forward but this
time they don't so he's ready to go with
a 221 kilowatt engine under the hood and
all-wheel drive on the road it can be
lots of fun to drift across the ice in
this seeit station wagon and racing mode
the Cupra handles very nimbly all the
stability assistance systems can be
switched off
sebastien explains that he's deactivated
the electronic stability control this is
known as the fun mode but only for
tracks away from public roads as we can
see he only keeps one hand on the
steering wheel because it's harder to
maintain full control with both hands on
it especially when drifting on snow and
ice in tricky conditions like these
drivers should steer and accelerate very
cautiously in small doses and with a
sensitive touch but at this test site
Sebastian can just step on the gas and
tackle the snowy terrain head-on
yes any remarks that the Leon Cupra has
a Haldex clutch which means that the car
tends to operate like a front-wheel
drive but as soon as the front wheel
starts spinning the electronics register
the sudden loss of traction and
activates the rear wheel drive too that
gets the car moving quickly especially
in snow this special all-wheel drive
technology is quite impressive in mili
second increments it distributes the
power to the wheels that need it most
car buyers would do well to take the
opportunity to test their limits in
training sessions like this one they'll
learn how to react in dangerous
situations so they can stay safe on the
road and have plenty of fun doing it
[Music]
you